nos dice un veterinario está estudiando
cierta enfermedad que parece estar
afectando a los gatos machos más que a
las hembras obtuvo una muestra aleatoria
de los registros de 500 gatos y encontró
que 24 de 259 machos tienen la
enfermedad mientras que 14 de 241
hembras la tienen el veterinario uso
estos resultados para probar su
hipótesis nula que es que la verdadera
proporción es igual tanto para los
machos como para las hembras contra su
hipótesis alternativa que dice que la
verdadera proporción de los machos es
mayor que la proporción de las hembras
el estadístico de prueba fue de 7 igual
a 1.46 y el valor p fue de
aproximadamente 0.07 supone que todas
las condiciones para la inferencia se
satisfacen
al nivel de significancia de alfa igual
a 0.10 hay suficiente evidencia para
concluir que una proporción más grande
de gatos machos tiene la enfermedad
pausa el vídeo y ver si puede
responderlo bien recuerda qué hacemos
con una prueba de significancia
suponemos que nuestra hipótesis nula es
verdadera déjame escribirlo y con esa
suposición vemos nuestros datos y
calculamos el valor p decimos cuál es la
probabilidad de obtener los datos que
tenemos al suponer que nuestra hipótesis
nula es verdadera si esa probabilidad es
menor que nuestro nivel de significancia
que al fahm entonces rechazamos la
hipótesis nula lo que sugeriría la
hipótesis alternativa
en este caso podemos ver que nuestro
valor pm es de 0.07 ya nos dan esta
información aquí lo tienes y este es
ciertamente menor que nuestro nivel de
significancia que alfa que toma el valor
de 0.10 y entonces por esa razón
rechazaríamos la hipótesis nula
rechazamos la hipótesis nula lo que
significa que podemos decir que hay
suficiente evidencia para concluir que
una proporción más grande de gatos
machos tiene esta enfermedad así que eso
en otras palabras quiere decir que
sugerimos la hipótesis alternativa en
khan academy hay preguntas de opción
múltiple como ésta así que la opción que
escojas podría ser algo como dado que
nuestro valor pm es menor que nuestro
nivel de significancia rechazamos la
hipótesis nula y eso quiere decir que
sugerimos la hipótesis alternativa y
hemos terminado nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo